a quarter of the global population has
received at least one dose of a covid-19
vaccine looks good at first glance but
the figure hides a serious problem
low-income countries are far behind just
one in a hundred have at least one jab
there
distribution is slowest in Africa there
just aren't enough doses the World
Health Organization has sharply
criticized the lack of action
the world is in vaccine apartheid
the lack of doses is having serious
knock-on effects for poorer countries
[Music]
and not enough vaccines means more
people catching the virus more
hospitalizations more deaths just take
Kenya where case levels are pushing
hospitals to the brink especially as
they run short of vital supplies Health
officials warn the highly contagious
Delta variant first identified in India
is responsible for the rise in
infections DW's Marielle Muller visited
a hospital in kisumu where they're
running dangerously short of medical
oxygen
um
screams for more oxygen the Intensive
Care Unit in kisumu hospital one of the
biggest in Kenya
nurse Nicolas otieno has seen a third of
his covet patients die
you might think the patient is improving
they might talk to you in one second and
then they just collapse and die
the ICU is full
otieno and his colleagues are
overwhelmed they just lost another
patient the hospital director is worried
they need five times more oxygen and far
more high flow oxygen machines than they
have
and we in Africa need those high flow
devices they are very expensive so we
can't afford them we lose lives that
could be saved because these devices are
not available
Health officials believe the number of
coronavirus cases is much higher than
recorded especially in villages where
people can't afford the transport to a
hospital
Jennifer awiti buried her younger sister
two days ago it went very fast she says
a bad headache fever shortness of breath
it all started on a Sunday when we were
in church she felt Unwell by the time
Saturday came it was too much for her to
Bear she was taken to hospital and the
same day she died
death has come to this Village residents
say there have been 50 burials here in
recent weeks
the only oxygen plant in the region has
reached breaking point and won't be able
to meet an increasing demand I'm getting
so many calls from a person who need to
be who need to be done Home Care
asking for option Regulators if you
don't assist them as fast as possible
then in the next few minutes that person
will be gone
back at kisumu hospital there's some
good news a patient who's been dependent
on oxygen for weeks will be released
soon somebody should not joke around
that no this thing is real
when you want to taste life
just try to remove whatever they're
giving you when you are in treatment
then you'll feel it
luck was on his side in a health system
so overstretched luck is what these
patients will need
and joining us now is director of the
Africa Centers for Disease Control and
prevention Dr John and kenga song Thank
you very much for taking the time to
speak with us today now before we get to
the supply shortages I just want to go
back to a statement that we heard
earlier from the chief of the who
do you agree with him that the world is
in in his words a vaccine apartheid
absolutely the you there's absolutely no
way you cannot say the world is in that
situation uh given the the serious
disparity in access to vaccines that we
are experiencing in Africa where overall
just above one percent of our population
of 1.2 billion people have been
vaccinated and um we actually don't know
when vaccines will begin to arrive the
continent at scale and our speed so it
is a very troubling situation it is a
situation that we have been saying it
should not be the case for months but
here we are with that situation here
especially in the midst of a very
aggressive third wave as you are
describing yes extremely serious
situation and you have previously said
Africa is not winning against the virus
so what needs to be done and who needs
to do it to get the continent in a
winning position
in uh in response and in anticipation of
exactly what we are going through uh on
the 8th of May we convene an emergency
meeting of all Ministers of Earth uh to
actually warn them raise an alarm that
what was happening in India could
actually happen here if you recall and
we said we need to do three things we
need what we call enhanced prevention we
need an enhanced monitoring and we
needed enhanced treatment where people
are actually countries actually stock
themselves up with oxygen where we knew
where the virus was circulating by
conducting surveillance and flushing out
the hot spots and where we were having
access to vaccines those are that is a
common strategy we agreed on the 8th of
May so this um was anticipated it was
predicted that we may actually be going
through a serious that wave and really a
stickling for Partnerships to support
countries to fight this very brutality
wave okay and we we saw just in our
report there the medical supply
shortages what are the biggest pressure
points on health care right now in Kenya
as we saw or in Ethiopia or Africa more
broadly
very broadly you see that uh Hospital
systems are overwhelmed uh healthcare
workers are overwhelmed we to start with
we don't have enough healthcare workers
so if Hospital yourself to now devote a
substantial amount and efforts and
resources to treating covet patients you
can very quickly see the damage and harm
that that is going to cause to other
endemic diseases on the continent so
we're dealing with a situation where the
the new variant the Delta variant is
spreading very aggressively and it
transmit over in excess of 40 more than
the ordinary variance there so that is
what is overwhelming that and it's not
just in Kenya we see that in Zambia we
have a swap team in in Zambia we have
teams that are heading to many African
countries to support them so the
situation is very alarming across uh all
across the continent okay so that's
about the spread of the Delta variant
making things even more difficult than
they normally would have been but were
hospitals ready and if they're still not
ready to accept this third wave what
needs to be done and how can they go
about it
my Our advice as the Africa CDC is that
uh countries would need to improvise and
begin to look at makeshift
scenarios where they can actually use an
Open Door an outdoor facilities to treat
patients like ruganda started doing
using sports arena and equip them with a
makeshift facilities to treat patients
because the hospitals are overwhelmed
and you do not build a hospital
overnight we do not develop Health
Systems and need them at the same time
you develop them before you need them so
we are completely in the middle of a
situation and scenario where we need to
improvise and develop a makeshift
treatment centers
all right well thank you very much for
your insights it's a very difficult
situation that Africa's facing right now
but uh hopefully there will be some kind
of way forward I mean there has to be Dr
John and kangasong from the Africa CDC
thank you very much for your time
thank you thank you
and now it's the part of the program
where we put one of your questions to
our science correspondent Derek Williams
can a person with HPV or cervical cancer
get the covid-19 vaccines
foreign
I need to give a little background on
this for an answer to make sense
HPV or human papilloma virus is a virus
transmitted mostly through sexual
contact that can cause warts or lesions
in in those who contract it it's
actually the most common STI worldwide
and it's also viewed as a risk factor
for later developing a range of
different types of cancers about 40
years ago German researcher haha
suhausen proved a direct link between
HPV and cervical cancer and was
eventually granted the Nobel Prize for
his work
in 2008 that research laid the
foundation for the development of HPV
vaccines and and gave rise to the
long-term goal of eventually wiping out
cervical cancer entirely by stopping the
transmission of HPV so so now you know
enough to go on let's get back to the
question
cancer patients as a rule have actually
been placed uh pretty high up on
priority lists in most national vaccine
campaigns doctors usually want their
patients to get the shots because
they're often heavily immunocompromised
hence in a pretty precarious place if
they do get SARS cov2 in fact
research is now showing that far from
posing a danger to cancer patients the
big worry is that covid-19 vaccines
won't stimulate a strong enough immune
response in them to fight off the
disease should they be exposed so
studies are also ongoing to see whether
cancer patients might require more shots
to achieve the same protective effects
if you have HPV or cervical cancer then
talk to your doctor of course before
being vaccinated but but in most cases I
assume the recommendation will be to get
your shot as soon as possible
foreign
's there and finally New York City put
on its party hat on Sunday for pretty
much the first time since the pandemic
began the annual Macy's fireworks show
lighting up skies in celebration of the
country's Independence Day the show was
bigger and brighter than last year's
more subdued event fans including
Coldplay performed and guests were once
again welcomed to the show the US hasn't
yet declared its independence from the
coronavirus though with vaccination
rates slowing President Joe Biden
telling Americans on Sunday that getting
a vaccine was the most patriotic thing
they could do and that's all for this
edition of our covid-19 special for more
you can check out the covid-19 section
on our website dw.com and we'll leave
you with these pictures for now until
next time thank you very much for
watching and take care
foreign
[Music]